vor kurzem haben wir ein video gemacht
auf unserem kanal über deutsche serien
und filme mit deutschen untertiteln und
dieses video war sehr populär
hier könnt ihr es noch mal angucken wenn
es verpasst hat und viele von euch
hatten auch tipps und ihr habt viele
kommentare geschrieben und wir sind
jetzt durch alle kommentare
durchgegangen und haben die tipps
gesucht die ihr am häufigsten genannt
hat die stellen wir euch heute vor und
deswegen zeigen wir euch heute mehr
deutsche serien und filme mit deutschen
untertiteln los geht's
am häufigsten habt ihr die netflix serie
dark genannt da es eine deutsche netz
kriegsproduktion und man kann dort auch
beim fx deutsche und anschalten wenn ihr
das mit deutschen untertiteln guckt
solltet ihr allerdings wissen dass die
untertitel nicht 100% präzise sind sie
sind für gehörlose produziert und das
heißt manchmal sind die untertitel auf
deutsch ein bisschen verkürzt unser
nicht genau die gleichen die gleiche
sprache die auch gesprochen wird das
solltet ihr wissen zum deutsch lernen
ist es aber trotzdem sicherlich
interessant der zweite tipp von euch ist
der youtube kanal kurz gesagt hier
findet ihr kurze videos mit animationen
zu verschiedenen wissenschaftlichen
themen und vielleicht habt ihr schon mal
davon gehört denn es gibt einen
englischen kanal der heißt in der
nahtstelle und das ist der meist
abonnierte kanal deutschlands die
gleichen videos findet ihr aber noch mal
auf einem deutschen kanal und dort gibt
es einen deutschen sprecher der sehr
deutlich und gleichmäßig spricht und
dazu gibt es 100 prozent präzise
untertitel das kann ich euch wirklich
empfehlen zum deutsch lernen
der dritte tipp ist eine serie namens
nikos weg darin geht es um einen jungen
mann der heißt nico und ist neu in
deutschland
das ganze ist so etwas wie eine
soap-opera für deutsch lernende und wird
von der deutschen welle produziert es
gibt 200 episoden und es fängt
tatsächlich in a 1 an also mit ganz
einfachen niveau und ganz einfachen
wörtern und später gibt es die 210
episode ist dann bei im b1 niveau man
kann also damit schritt für schritt
deutschland guckt es euch mal an
jetzt haben wir noch drei sendungen die
ihr genannt hat die interessant sind für
deutsch lerne aber leider nicht so
präzise untertitel haben oder manchmal
auch gar keine untertitel das erste ist
galileo das ist eine wissenssendung und
es läuft auf dem privaten fernsehsender
prosieben und jeden tag berichten sie
über ganz unterschiedliche themen
das zweite sind die tagesthemen das ist
eine nachrichtensendung die wird vom
öffentlich rechtlichen sender ard
produziert und das ist vielleicht so
etwas wie die beste nachrichtensendung
in deutschland und es gibt auch eine app
dazu ich gucke die zum beispiel auch
jeden tag und das ist sehr interessant
für euch auch um zu sehen wie gucken
deutsche überhaupt nachrichten oder
welche themen sind gerade in deutschland
interessant wie berichten deutsche
darüber und das dritte ist der youtube
kanal mister wissen
dort berichtet ein journalist namens
mirco über verschiedene
gesellschaftliche und politische themen
und er erklärt diese auf einfache weise
für jugendliche oder eigentlich für alle
menschen und er macht das wirklich sehr
gut und sehr anschaulich und er spricht
auch eine sehr klare und ruhige sprache
dabei deshalb ist das auch zum deutsch
lernen ganz gut auch wenn die untertitel
nicht immer ganz präzise sind
zum schluss habe ich noch einen spezial
tipp für euch von unserem freund jeremy
der hat nämlich eine google chrome
extension gefunden mit der man
untertitel in netflix anzeigen lassen
kann und zwar ist das eine extension die
live untertitel oder quasi die
untertitel live übersetzt
sie funktioniert allerdings noch nicht
hundertprozentig zuverlässig deswegen
probiert sie einfach mal selbst aus den
link posten wie hier unten in der
infobox
und wenn ihr lust habt jetzt noch mehr
deutsch mit und hatte in zu lernen dann
probiert doch mal unsere app ceiling aus
denn dort könnt ihr nicht nur
videomaterial mit untertiteln sehen
sondern ihr habt auch interaktive
untertitel ihr könnt auf die wörter
draufklicken ihr bekommt übersetzungen
und grammatische informationen und dabei
könnt ihr ja verschiedene geschichten
sehen ihr könnt vokabeln lernen unseren
vokabeltrainer und ihr könnt auch spiele
spielen interaktive übungen machen
probiert das mal aus hier geht es zu
singen und wir freuen uns sehr auf euer
feedback danke fürs zuschauen und bis
nächste woche
[Musik]
das ist gut